all right to a disturbing story out of
washington d.c two men accused of posing
as homeland security agents now face new
weapons charges to remember this story
prosecutors have laid out more evidence
now against the suspects who they say
gave gifts to secret service agents and
those agents are now sidelined as this
investigation is ongoing senior
investigative correspondent catherine
herridge is following this alarming case
we don't really know the motive here yet
catherine good morning
that's right good morning tony we're
about two weeks into this case and
there's so many unknowns the motive
where the money came from and now a
grand jury has brought new charges the
27-page indictment shows the two
defendants ariane tahurzadeh and haider
ali face multiple counts including the
false impersonation of an officer or
employee of the united states
and the unlawful possession of a large
capacity ammunition feeding device in
this case one glock magazine and five
sig sauer magazines the government
alleges the defendant sought to
ingratiate themselves with their d.c
neighbors in law enforcement by posing
as homeland security agents prosecutors
allege the men had five apartments in a
luxury building and gifted agents
electronics and rent-free units
including a penthouse valued at over 40
thousand dollars a year earlier this
month the government went even further
alleging they compromised u.s secret
service personnel with access to the
white house now suspended secret service
personnel assigned to the first lady the
white house and the vice president's
residence before the new charges both
defendants were released to home
confinement pending trial one defendant
had visas for travel to iran and
pakistan one of the lingering questions
vlad is whether the scheme was designed
to collect information for the benefit
of a foreign intelligence service
catherine still a lot of questions thank
you so much we appreciate it